Britain's classrooms may be full of
students but filling them with teachers
is increasingly difficult a struggle in
math science and language subjects that
we're looking to fill with International
recruits from countries like India
Nigeria and Jamaica
unions say it's a quick fix for a broken
system I think the reality is that it's
nothing more than a sticking cluster but
even then
um a sticking plaster where the wound is
continuing to gape and frankly The
Exodus of teachers is continuing uh to
take place so you know the reality is
it's not it's not even going to be a
policy that will tide us over Tiding
these overseas teaches over will be a
ten thousand pound Grant to cover
relocation costs initially up to 400
could be recruited to start this
September some say that money could be
better spent James is a secondary school
teacher in southeast London and has
spent six days on strike this year so
far campaigning for better pay I think
this pilot kind of is is the wrong uh
we're talking about wrong priorities
here the priority needs to be to reduce
workload for staff reduce class sizes
increase pay form all teachers and
support staff and ensure that schools
are fully funded
because that's what's going to start to
actually address this crisis
the government says it's aware of the
strength of feeling and that this scheme
is one of a number of ways it's looking
to address Recruitment and Retention the
Department of Education told us in March
we launched a one-year trial offering no
more than 400 of the very best teachers
from around the world the opportunity to
teach in our schools this is one of many
options we are exploring to ensure there
is an excellent teacher for every child
but it's leaving some to question why
there's not enough of them here
[Music]